alright i know this is gonna disappoint
a ton of you guys
but i'm almost certain that the new
larger imac coming later this year
is still gonna have a chin and i'm gonna
explain why in this video
using some common sense as well as some
hints and tidbits
that i've recently figured out so let's
get right into it now before we begin
i want to give you guys some good news
and mention that in my opinion
there's a 50 50 chance that the larger
imac
actually comes with black bezels but i'm
gonna get into that in just a minute
but for now let's talk about the chin
the first question we have to answer
is why apple gave the new 24-inch imac
the chin
in the first place a lot of people are
going to say that the only reason they
kept it was so they could fit
the entire computer behind the chin and
keep it as thin as possible
yes that is totally true but in my
personal opinion
that wasn't the number one reason i
believe that apple's number one
requirement for the imac redesign
was quite literally to keep the chin and
here's why
the 24 inch imac is basically a
reincarnation
of the classic imac g3 and we know that
because it had white bezels
a chin and essentially the same color
options on
everything from the mac itself to the
mouse and the keyboard
and if you think about it every single
imac that featured the built into the
display concept
starting with the imac g5 in 2004 came
with the chin
and then the 2007 imac which came with
the chin
and then the 2012 imac which came with
the chin
and the main reason why they did that is
because that chin has always been
totally unique to apple
and has become an iconic design aspect
of
the imac making it instantly
recognizable
compared to every other all-in-one pc
out there
and that's why the 24-inch imac still
has the chin
it's iconic and believe it or not it's
the chin
that sells it for apple wanna know how i
know that well
take a look at all of these all-in-one
pcs they basically all have at least
some sort of a chin
with branding on it because they want it
to look like the classic imac but i did
find
a couple of them without a chin so take
a guess
just by looking at it which brand this
one is from
if you guessed hp you're wrong it's from
lenovo
and how about this one who made this all
in one
if you guessed dell you're wrong it's hp
and what about this one
yeah you get the point and that's the
main reason why it makes sense for apple
to keep the chin
for the larger imac as well but don't
worry because the chin
is actually going to look quite a lot
slimmer than the one on the 24 inch imac
and let me prove it to you believe it or
not but there were actually three sizes
of the core 2 dual imac
with white bezels a 17 inch a 20 inch
and a 24 inch and if you look closely
the chin is exactly the same thickness
on each model
looking quite a bit slimmer on the
largest 24 inch
and then on the 2007 aluminum bezel
models the chin
was also the same thickness and the same
thing for the slimmer imac design
that everybody has right now both the
21.5 inch and
27 inch imacs have the same exact
chin thickness so here's the point that
i'm trying to make
the chin on the larger imac is actually
going to look pretty slim
because it's going to be the same exact
thickness as the one on the 24 inch
but the display will be scaled up to as
much as
30 inches so the chin will look pretty
slim
like in this image created by a mac
rumors forum user
and since i believe that it's gonna have
a chin it's extremely unlikely
that it'll get a large 32 inch display
because it'll simply be too big being
even bigger than the size of the pro
display xdr
now since apple is going to scale the
imac up to basically look like a larger
version of the 24 inch imac
they can get away with making the body
itself thicker
while maintaining the same balanced
ratio in terms of the dimensions
for example a 30 inch display is 25
larger than a 24 inch display so they
can
actually make the body up to 25 thicker
so instead of being 11.5 millimeters
thin
like on the 24 inch they can actually
make the larger imac
a couple of millimeters thicker without
impacting the dimensions too much
and if you really think about it the
current 27 inch imac
is already 15 thicker than the 21 and a
half inch
so i expect them to do the exact same
thing on the larger imac
especially if it's getting a 30 inch
display what this essentially means is
that apple will
actually be able to fit in a more
powerful m1x chip
along with all of the other components
behind
the chin just like they're already doing
with the 24
inch and if you think about it the chin
on the larger imac
is also going to be much longer allowing
for a
longer logic board with more space for
other cooling components and wherever
else they need
so yeah i'm actually pretty confident
that apple will still be able to fit
the entire computer in the chin of the
larger imac
even with more performance and if that
wasn't enough for you
here are a few more pieces of evidence
pointing to the larger imac
getting a chin the new 24 inch imac has
a variety of different colors
but one of them is missing apple's
signature space gray
the fact that apple left that color
option out basically means that they're
planning to introduce it
in a larger imac and if that imac did
not have a chin
and it was all display in black bezels
there wouldn't really be that big of a
point to the space gray color option
since you could only really see it from
the side or from the back
so it makes sense to keep the chin
around for that space gray color but as
far as the other color options i
honestly don't know if all of them will
make it
or if apple is gonna try to keep the
larger imac more subtle with more
neutral colors
but i actually think that there's a
chance that apple could be
keeping the bezels white if you think
about it apple's larger imacs have
always looked
fundamentally identical to the smaller
models
so giving it black bezels would be a bit
weird unless
they decide to call it the imac pro and
then that changes
everything i initially thought that
that's what apple is gonna do
but after the release of the 24 inch
imac that definitely changed my
perspective a little bit
and i actually think that there's a
chance that apple could be releasing
two more imac models but that's another
topic for another video
so if you're interested in seeing that
video definitely subscribe
down below so you don't miss out now as
far as the specs of this new imac
i think the display resolution will be
somewhere between 5.2 and 5.5 k
depending on if it's getting a 28 or 30
inch display and i don't think that it's
going to be getting many led tech
it's going to be sticking to the
standard lcd and as for the chipset the
absolute simplest way for apple to
manufacture
this larger imac is to give every model
the m1x chip just like they did with the
m1 on the 24 inch imac
but there's also a small chance that it
could have
a more expensive m1z upgrade option
but i'm not really sure about this just
yet now we also heard rumors of apple
working on a dedicated
graphics chip for a larger imac coming
in the second half of this year
so that will likely be an upgrade option
that you'll have to pay
extra for if it comes it'll definitely
come with up to 32 gigabytes of ram
or maybe even 64 but i'm not really sure
about that
and will probably have up to eight
terabytes of ssd storage
just like on the current 27 inch imac so
there you guys go
that's pretty much all of my thoughts on
the new larger imac coming later this
year
and if you totally disagree with my
point of view
go ahead and comment your thoughts down
below but if you enjoyed this video
click that circle above to subscribe for
more videos like this one
definitely check out one of those two
right there thanks for watching and
we'll see you in
the next video
[Music]